look at Lambeau Field November 6
November 6 Wow who says there's global
warming Chris don't get me started my
don't get me freaking started on the
conversation it's a joke please it's a
joke snowing at Lambeau Field they're
throwing snowballs at practice Lambeau
Field will be the site of Sunday's game
between the Panthers and the Packers and
that is the template for the first
question of what's more likely whose
struggles are more likely to continue
against Carolina the Packers offense or
the Packers defense
yeah well the Packers defense played
well last week you know they they kept
the kept the team in there for a long
time even though the offense couldn't
get going and I mean it was six nothing
forever and they gave them chances but I
think ultimately if I'm gonna pick here
I'm gonna say the defense's struggle
until more than anything I just I just
look at the offense oh it's it's been an
upward trend really since week two or
three of the NFL season last week yes
they certainly had a hiccup didn't play
well but I just look at them and go
Aaron Rodgers I think a little four and
then we'll get back to the running game
a little bit and the Panthers offense as
you know it has some sneaky talent with
McCaffrey yes we know about him but
Curtis Samuel and DJ Moore and Norv
Turner is very creative and what he does
where I think he poses some problems for
that defense this week and keep in mind
Christian McCaffrey the Panthers running
back missed practice on Wednesday with
the knee injury it's believed to be a
maintenance day that they're trying to
they're trying to keep him together for
as long as they can because he's the
heart and soul of anything now moving
forward and I agree with you the Packers
defense has been gradually
disintegrating over the past month and a
half yep the offense has gotten better
and better they just had one of those
days where they walked into a buzzsaw
and it happens and now you move on to
your next team and I think that the the
Panthers are going to ultimately regret
very severely the fact that the Packers
lost to the Chargers last week because I
don't think the Packers are going to let
it go to two in a row and I think
they're going to have everything ready
for the Panthers but still the defense
is going to have a hard time
next one quarterback more likely to be
on his current team next year Derek Carr
or Philip Rivers what's more like man
this is a tough one here this really is
but I'm gonna go with Derek Carr I am I
mean Derek Carr's played really well I
mean he had the bonehead mistake in
Green Bay but other than that I can't
look at too many moments where I go I
don't like that now Philip Rivers has
played well too don't get me wrong but
he is at a age and I do see skills
declining and at some point it's an
organization that needs to move on and
start the next chapter so if you're
gonna make me choose one of the other
there which you are I'm going to say the
Derek Carr is more likely to be on the
race they're exceeding expectations
right now and I just have a hard time if
they continue to do this and just hang
around the playoff conversation hard I
think as an organization to say no it's
the quarterbacks fault we're gonna move
on because he's been pretty spot-on
right so far I think it's more likely
the car will be back but I still think
it's close to being unlikely that he'll
be back either and I look he made some
comments after the the win over the
Lions where you know we've changed so
many things since I've been here
hopefully we won't make changes yeah
hopefully they won't get rid of me I'm
building my house next door to Jon
Gruden in Las Vegas she can't leave me
behind but mike Mayock said it himself
when they were evaluating calamari and
Dwayne Haskins before the draft why are
you looking at those guys it's simple we
have a constant obligation to try to
upgrade at every position including
quarterback and that was the clearest
indication that that I could discern
that the Raiders are not committed long
term to Derek Carr they've escaped all
the guaranteed money after this year it
becomes a year-to-year contract I think
it's a foregone conclusion Rivers isn't
gonna be back unless he engineers a
playoff run but I think it's it's still
it's still far from being a likelihood
or even a probability the car will be
back and you know I guess I guess here's
the easiest way to say it if either of
those teams doesn't make the playoffs I
think there's a very high chance that
their quarterbacks won't be back next
year getting to the playoffs is going to
be the key to save Derek Carr in Oakland
or
Vegas or Phillip burgers me to say one
thing there to did Derek Carr find a new
house in Las Vegas find a new house
don't live next to John that's just I I
mean I'm just saying that's just a
disaster waiting to happen it's just
it's not smart I don't know they're
gonna say it you know I don't you know I
just would not suggest it for any
starting quarterback and especially a
starting quarterback for John Gurdon
who's psycho at quarterbacks he'll
evaluate you while you're at home you
know there's another family barbecue he
could be over here at the facility
working oh there he is playing horse in
the driveway look can't even hit a
three-pointer oh gosh he's my damn
quarterback I mean that's the things
coaches do there he's setting himself up
for you know oh if you don't play well
well damned if he wasn't you know always
in the backyard with his friends at the
pool maybe he'd play better that's where
I would be scared I would tell Derek are
you got a lot of money man build another
house somewhere else I really would I
really hate to say this that may be the
best point you've ever made I'm fine I
wish I'd thought of it right that's the
thing you know it's a really good point
when somebody makes it and you'd never
thought of it and you're like damn I
wish I'd thought of that he's gonna be
like looking out the window seeing what
time they turn the lights up no doubt
right right Gruden's gonna be at Gulf
gosh he's getting up at 8:15 my
quarterbacks freaking lazy what the
hell's going on here he'll know Gruden's
not gonna be there he's gonna have mrs.
Brewton
when you get up go see if they don't see
if they've taken the garbage out yet
next door you know keep an eye on what
time you see him roll out of there
listen for listen for his car to start
because he's not here he's grinding yeah
yeah yeah Derek you're making a mistake
buddy all right which banged up
quarterback is more likely to throw
three touchdowns this week
Patrick mahomes against the Titans or
Jacoby Brissette against the Dolphins
I'm going the homes here all the way I
mean I mean three touchdowns for Patrick
mahomes is like a ho-hum Oh three
touchdowns oh we won't even talk about
it on the news it's it's that's what he
does right that's just like everybody
else throwing one touchdown so yeah I do
and I think the Titans are aggressive in
the secondary it will lend itself to
some some
plays some big place in the past game
and would jacobi per set his injury
being a little more recent maybe they
rely on the run game a little bit more
when they get close down in the red zone
too so that's why I got my homes yeah I
agree with you and I think it's a
greater likelihood that my homes is
going to play he fully participated in
practice on Wednesday Brissette was
limited they've called Brissette week to
week with that MCL injury there is no
guarantee that he's gonna play and I
think it's a much greater chance we're
gonna see mahomes last one which New
York coach is more likely to get fired
if he loses this week in the Battle of
New York / New Jersey Pat Shermer of the
Giants or Adam GaSe of the Jets ah man I
hate talking about guys getting fired
but I know you don't well I do I do
cuz I know these guys are people who are
like putting their heart and soul into
the job here but I'll do this let me say
this right let's just to the extent that
there is some belief that we shouldn't
talk about coaches getting fired
number one it happens every year I know
with firing 25% of the coaches every
year it would no longer be a point of
conversation second they all have
buyouts they get paid to not coach at
least for one two or three years except
for the guys whose contracts are
expiring and third it goes with the
territory Chris this Academy signed up
for not talking about it I mean all your
points are yes they're spot on but I'm
still not I'm still allowed not to like
talking about it all right you jerk okay
but if you're gonna make me do that I'm
going with Adam GaSe I just don't think
it's in the Giants DNA right now and
especially with a rookie quarterback
Daniel Jones who's you know in the midst
of this rookie year and supplanting Eli
Manning and all of those kind of things
I feel like the Jets are more of the
organization that would make the move I
feel like the Jets um fans and media
following here in the New York area is a
little more what do I want to say
vibrant or just mad at Adam GaSe as
compared to the Giants with Pat Sherman
because I I think the Giants fans
expected this season to be somewhat
around where it is maybe not you know 2
& 6 or are they 2 & 6 or 2 & 7
2
seven but I don't think there was
expectations but the Jets I think
everybody thought oh we might be
competitive this year and I think that's
where I go with Adam GaSe yeah and look
I think on the merits it would make more
sense for Shermer to be in trouble
because we've seen a bigger body of work
from him over the last year and a half
but there is a sense that the dam is
starting to break for the Jets and the
more that Adam GaSe says he doesn't care
about it I think that makes it even
worse there's a certain point where you
have to care about it or the fans are
just gonna think you don't care about
anything do you care about winning do
you care about anything what are you
worried about what are you doing and and
I think that you know for a lot of these
coaches they don't spend enough time
playing the game of getting the fans to
believe that they truly are committed to
everything the fans are committed to and
if they care as much as the coaches care
right and it just feels like and and it
also it doesn't help that the media
coverage of the Jets has been far more
negative in New York then it's been of
the giant it has that adds to it as well
and I look I think what's gonna happen
is at some point woody Johnson's gonna
come back he's gonna fire everybody he's
gonna hire a Rex Ryan that's what I
think is gonna happen here but I think
it's an I figured put me down in the
time capsule for that one Woody Johnson
will be back within the next two years
and he'll hire Rex for oh my god [ __ ] I
don't even have I don't even know how to
respond to that that would be
unbelievable everybody would be I
wouldn't suggest it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports